the america's richest families list
looks at the wealthiest families
uh in the united states so it doesn't
include
just individual fortunes somebody like
warren buffett or elon musk
this looks more at multi-generation
families um
you know people who it may be they may
be two generations in they may be five
generations in
when you think of the richest families
in america oftentimes
you know you would think of somebody
like the vanderbilts
uh or the ass stores or something like
that interestingly
neither of those two families are among
the wealthiest families in america
today you know over time fortunes tend
to dissipate
this year the walton family tops
the list and they are worth a
whopping 247 billion dollars the waltons
are
the shareholders of walmart it was
founded by
sam walton and his brother bud and
the company pays the family which owns
about half
of walmart about 700 million dollars a
year
in dividends um it's quite quite a
fortune that they have
after that it's the coke family which is
you know charles coke
and julia coke uh who is the widow of
david coke and then
there are two other koch brothers uh who
had inherited this
estate from their father uh that family
was worth about a hundred billion
dollars
and coke industries is the largest
private company in america
and they do everything for you know the
oil they
they own um brawny paper towels
um just a huge conglomerate and then
number three on the list is the mars
family behind the candy company eminem
mars
them about half of mars revenue though
is actually from pet food
um the family members don't run the
company but they sit on some of them sit
on the board it's a fairly secretive
also privately held company
i think one of the things that's
interesting is the families might not be
household names but products that they
produce
certainly are you know people may not
have heard of the show and family but
they've certainly heard of uhaul
uh you might not have heard the fisher
family but you definitely under you know
definitely no gap you've probably never
heard of the gore family but you may
have heard of gore-tex
you might not know the taylor family uh
but you know enterprise rent-a-car
it's kind of a crazy time um in the
stock markets right so we're in this
pandemic
we've got food lines across the country
you know people are
worried about getting evicted if
infections aren't banned
going forward and then you have new
billionaires apparently coming out you
know seemingly coming out of the
woodwork
with you know initial public offerings
happen the stock market's
going crazy and so this is kind of on
that other ext you know this
a reminder of this incredible wealth
inequality in our country where we have
these
families that hold so much wealth
you